[Music]
because as you said earlier Mark Harley
is in his ear
and
um he's giving him good advice Mark
Harley is is in his ear okay
and much like Virgie nobody knows why
he's around
so
um oh I'm here for you to give credit to
Marsh for the things I said that's what
that's what I'm here for oh I said that
you [ __ ] no I said he bit the hands and
feet oh it's a bit to hand the feed him
part
don't Gaslight me you're so [ __ ]
crazy
all right
as Virgie said earlier by himself with
all bulb came up from his brain yep it
was just me Mark Harley is just [ __ ]
well okay so here's this this Mark
Harley trying to sell a joke and nobody
wants it he was actually commenting on
um math in this video so I thought you
guys might pick interest in just a
mathematics sort of analysis right here
in the newspaper the other day you can
recite pi to 200 decimals that's nice
but you look like a geek so who gives a
[ __ ] cause you ain't gonna get laid
you're gonna let the club start reciting
pie to a hoe the worst game I've ever
seen I saw some [ __ ] kid in the
newspaper the other day you can recite
pie
I'm not that I'm bored okay yeah
oh no oh yeah
yeah he missed on that one
is that good game though I'm a
professional comic
but first off even if you aren't been
doing it forever you can have two Comics
that disagree if something's funny or
not right I'm not I'm not a mark Harley
side here by any means because Mark
Carly did go to San Francisco comedy
college so you're not a decorated comic
like he is a Brian but the other thing I
want to point out is well well I agree
it's funny seeing Mark Carly fall in his
face
now you're about to see
Brian Callan and Brendan Schaub
criticize Andrew Tate for being exactly
like they are because his video is the
same thing as like man these two these
two guys make a fun of us being us they
don't even play any sports or play or
Crush any puss how is that a difference
how is that a different stance than what
you guys have like I I love I love this
mentality that that it's like you guys
don't do the same thing I'm not saying
we're better [ __ ] we we we we any
[ __ ] hot news chick we're gonna
[ __ ] completely just objectify them I
get it but I'm also not here yelling at
other people for doing it you know that
was that good game if you were going to
a club instead of reciting pie yeah but
the kids
that kid's gonna be somebody's boss
someday
Frozen is that you I'm a fan of Andrew
Tate with something but some of it when
I got kids yeah well but I like that
[ __ ] if he was older I'd be on board but
when it's a young kid it's just like
yeah you might not get the same chicks
you do repotting piece but you don't
think it's that funny Mark there's no no
you got a good sense of humor you got a
good sense okay this is like this is
like
bro this is like the least funniest in
the world person in the world telling
another guy you're normally so funny
yeah dude come on man you're better than
this holy [ __ ]
Jesus Christ talk about the blah talk
about the the brain dead leading the gay
like what is this
you guys are taking it literally like
he's bullying a kid well the kid's gonna
no you guys can't see the irony in that
you can't see the what in it
the irony you can't see the okay hold on
pseudo-intellectual I think I'm so smart
called it irony you don't like irony I
wrote are you like ironing
you don't see the ironing in that the
kid's gonna no you guys can't see the
irony in that no well no maybe watch it
again no I don't think it's like for me
he missed it you think he's actually
like vicious
he did that [ __ ] he did that bit to be
funny I'm gonna tell you something right
now if you ever try to sell a joke
you've sent this hard I'd kill you like
this should not be a four minute video
no no no bro but you're not you don't
get it though why it's good this is just
you don't get that it's funny you don't
think that it's funny I realize now that
anything that I I'm gonna purposefully
find [ __ ] now that's just not funny and
I'm going to sell it for I don't know
it's pretty good I don't know guys
[ __ ] not because you see because you
see like you see Frozen said the thing
about Nick or cater's channel right and
then like 20 minutes later
and and it was the late response and the
stoner brain of that's what made it so
funny Kanye West was Kanye West was
right about pessie
sometimes you miss him but it's okay
there's three out of the four people in
the room and Chin didn't crack a smile
tinting and crack a smile what is this
we've been covering you for a long time
Brendan you never used to do this what's
going on were you watching a lot of old
Star Trek
seriously right he's doing [ __ ]
Shatner at this point I just posted a
screenshot and Show links of uh of the
[ __ ] San Francisco comedy College
I'm sorry I don't know why not is that
really it we never looked it up on
Google yeah why none of us have ever
looked up the street view the
prestigious there it is the prestigious
San Francisco comedy college right next
to which has California parking two
dollars an hour
so Chinatown so it's you know it's
quality so it's basically like on the
fourth floor of a building yes
yes next to a dentist in between another
dentist
a lot of the stuff I didn't I don't
crack a smile I don't either a lot of it
I agree with and a lot of it I'm like
hey Miss there that what he missed I
don't have a problem with it Brennan
your shorts are obscenely short
they are really really short like
that is even regardless of the style
that's uncomfortable especially on a
leather chair because in the back of
your thighs get sweaty and then you
stick to it
like you're gonna take some swings I
don't even [ __ ] it's all right I still
like killing people and so they don't
laugh at something I don't go oh I guess
I'm wrong no no no no if you like it
[ __ ] yeah but
children and I agree with most his stuff
like most his stuff is funny like a lot
of it's fun we've defended him a lot
yeah no I like Andrew Taylor that was
just a clumsy move that's also for me
for me sarcasm
Bryant Brian Brian Brian Brian Brian and
this part's good coming up it's real
quick Brian
clumsy move says the guy who wanted to
get the federal authorities involved
with Bobby Lee over a Reddit thread
you know says the guy who clumsily used
to pull his dick out in cars also for me
it'll be both of them sarcasm irony yeah
yeah for me
hello in the room was amazing
for you
they literally are just they just we're
reduced to going yeah
[Music]
so met children before I think if it was
an older kid
it was like an older kid oh my God why
are you defending this so hard bro
everybody on this show has bombed before
we've bombed many times on this show he
can't he can't let it go take the L
sometimes multiple multiple times a show
I mean seriously [ __ ] Pro Sunday
night [ __ ] show is just a bunch of
people screaming over each other and
bombing so what
and in fighting
that kid's not yes yeah if he was if he
was 13 to be funny
he's
he's a baby
he is being he is pouting look at him
he's pouting he's doing the passive
aggressive if it was if it was 13 it'd
be fine
said it you guys be laughing oh
brilliant this this is like this is the
best most glaring view we've ever seen
of like his insecurity it's [ __ ]
mind-boggling
I bet I bet if Will Sasso said that joke
you guys would be hysterical I said you
don't like me it's because I'm I mean
I'm intimidate you because I go on the I
go on the dark weapon buy a bunch of
stuff and put in a body
because I'm a genius he's an N person he
sure is
that about it he did that about my kid
I'd lose my [ __ ] mind yeah what would
you do because you keep losing your mind
we stop saying that sandals kick his ass
in your flip-flops you do that about my
kids that I barely ever see oh man it's
[ __ ] on bro it's on like Donkey Kong
bro
17 I got an 11 year old
laughs
kids are I've also met children before
oh my God he's not letting it go really
upset his really bummed mark
Let It Go
this doesn't matter that much
Jesus Christ yeah
yeah that's fine what else you got
by the way there's two minutes left in
this so I think whatever else Mark has
next is going to be passive aggressive
Rick what do you want Mark Mark got all
sensitive now now Mark's almost wait a
second
they smell blood
that's exactly all you're we all know
what this is like this is the best oh
you don't show weakness like guys you
idiots
you need Linda you lean into it if I
would have showed this and these two
like Virgie and Marsh were like that's
not funny man but that's not funny but
Virg's like yeah I have kids bro that's
not bad like I don't give a [ __ ] about
your kids and that's how I would have
ended that's it I would have joked it
off and nobody cared nobody would have
cared it would have been fine
you guys just you guys just went no
that's not funny it's because of a kid
and you know like I have kids
that's right when a joke doesn't go over
merch merch you she used to stand up
when a truck doesn't go over you just
keep trying and then eventually no no
that's not true Royce eventually give up
and the more they make funny then you
start they need to take the Stuttering
John approach you start personally
attacking people and then when they go
bro what the [ __ ] you go well we're just
joking around we'll [ __ ] have fun no
we didn't think it was funny that's fine
yeah the two comics in the room
everybody
yeah one and a half no this is hey hey
no it doesn't um I get it I just taste
different tastes yeah but again
the two comics
how [ __ ] Dare You Brendan
I'll give calendar pass because Callan
is gonna stand up for a long time yeah
but come on
I wouldn't leave a comment I wouldn't
leave a comment on them like not funny
enough I don't know he's roid raging
that's fine
it's fine are you on Trend Trend makes
people really angry
all right but Mark he can release stuff
on social media still or this somebody
else yeah what was that was that because
he can't didn't they ban him he's Rumble
Rumble
that was a YouTube video that somebody
else made oh gotcha he's pissed yeah
because so he's still allowed to be on
YouTube as long as somebody else no no
that's why he's on Rumble that's why I
signed exclusively with Rumble
now Mark feels bad because people are
going to give him a hard time
Brian's really throwing him under the
bus well Brian you are correct I don't
think Brian likes him very much I don't
think Brian likes him I believe that if
we're being honest Mark Carly is one
that was forced on everyone on everyone
because of Brendan and and then when
Theo left it just made Mark's [ __ ]
presence even more
no I don't do that no I imagine kids no
I imagine most people like if you're
Andrew I get why I get why you thought
it was funny like
oh my God it's like a kid where they
have to go no it's okay buddy
get I get the idea of like he's he's
it's kind of an outrageous thing to do
they are literally backing off on their
stance because they hurt his feelings
on a comedy show that's supposed to have
Comics over an angel Tate video can you
can you and this I always think about
this stuff can you imagine the same
scenario but it was a studio of Colin
Quinn and Patrice O'Neal like those guys
can you imagine what would have happened
they would have eviscerated Mark Carly
for being a baby about it oh yeah
other people saying something isn't
funny he's clearly being entertained
there is clearly being he's clearly
being over the top sarcastic that's what
he's doing and again because I get the
joke as the kid he's making fun of a kid
oh my God bro they're still explaining
it
he's not making fun of the kid he's
going dude you can't try to chatting
woman up and but the kid's never gonna
be in a club so I get what you're saying
I get that yeah he I don't think he's
making fun of the kid he's making he's
making fun of memory like you're special
remember
but also the fact that the kids I don't
know what's going on right now we're
analyzing it I get what Mark says what
it is the kid's never going to be in a
club anyway chatting up a girl so he's
he's like hitting the kid with producers
the only
this produces the only one with any sort
of a [ __ ] idea of what broadcasting
yes yes all right guys let's just move
on guys please if anybody takes issue
with me laughing at this joke he'll beat
him up please no no I won't beat him up
nobody's going to take issues no I'll
discuss it with them in public or in
private or don't because nobody cares
it's a non-issue I just wish they would
let him back on [ __ ] social media
social why do you miss him I thought you
weren't on social media Brandon he's
doing this voice now I don't know when
it started enough people are gonna make
fun of it that he's gonna do a different
voice Baba